[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I'm standing here
with Topher of Rain
Forest Connection.
Topher, tell us
about the project.
TOPHER WHITE: We're a nonprofit
startup based in San Francisco.
We build open source
scalable solutions
to legal logging, poaching,
and environmental protection.
Really just making sure
that we can use technology
to help protect the planet.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really awesome.
The whole project is both
incredible and inspiring.
How did you come to the idea
and start with the execution?
TOPHER WHITE: Well,
this all kind of
started by realizing there's
people out in the field,
there's people on the
ground in the rain forest
who really would
protect it if they
had the right tools
and the right support.
But a lot of times, some of
that support is technological,
and so if we need them to
help protect the forests,
because they're the
ones to do it the best,
and protecting the forest
is one of the best ways
to fight climate change,
then one of the best ways
to fight climate change
would be to build technology
to help these people
protect their forest.
And a lot of times
that means they
need to be able to protect it
from destruction, invasion,
all these sorts of things.
So that's what we're
trying to build.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And tell
us just a little bit more
about the technology.
How does it work?
What does it do?
TOPHER WHITE: So basically we
take old, upcycled cell phones,
we put them in a box with
solar panels and a microphone,
and we put them up in
trees in the rain forest.
They can listen to all
the sounds of the forest
and stay there for years.
They stream it all
up to the cloud,
and then we use AI,
TensorFlow, to be
able to pick out the sounds
of chain saws, logging trucks,
really any species
we're looking for,
and send alerts to
people on the ground
so they can show up
and stop logging trucks
and loggers in real time.
But not just them,
we can make this
available to the whole world.
So we can bring the rain
forest to the entire planet
in real time.
And that's something that
couldn't have been possible
too many years ago.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
you actually partnered
with some middle school
students in Los Angeles
to help build these devices.
How hard was it to get them
up to speed on the technology?
TOPHER WHITE: One of the most
amazing things about this
is they were using tools
that already exist,
using TensorFlow for the
analysis up in the cloud.
We're reusing old cell phones,
old smartphones to actually
be the sensors in the field.
And all these things
are pretty sturdy.
So we can just
work with students
to teach them that IoT,
the Internet of Things,
is not about new
technologies always.
Sometimes it's about what's here
right in front of us right now.
And so they are pretty
good at taking old phones,
put them in boxes with
microphones and solar panels,
and ship them off
to the rain forest.
And that's really
important, because we
want to be able to show
that the work that they
do with their hands, and
the connections they forge
with the tribes, the
people on the ground,
actually can last well
beyond our impact.
So these next generations being
able to build and actually
be part of these
projects going forward,
and to have that real-time
connection, the streaming
sound from the forest, that has
a whole new level of impact.
It all started here
in San Francisco was
some pretty awesome students,
and now it's expanded to LA,
and hopefully we can see
it expand beyond that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's been the
impact of the project so far?
TOPHER WHITE: Well,
we actually can
say we're actively aiding
in the protection of 1,000
square miles of rain forest.
We've been active
on four continents,
and we're hoping
to really double
that to go to about 2,000
square miles of forest
over the next six
to eight months.
And that's really what
this is all about.
That becomes possible by
using scalable technology,
like TensorFlow, like
old Android phones,
and with people on the ground.
Because there's so many
people out in the forest
that would help if they
just had the right tools
and the right support.
And we're going to
give it to them.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank
you for joining us.
Thank you for
sharing this story,
and thank you for
the work that you do.
TOPHER WHITE: Thank you for
all that you guys do, too.
We couldn't do without the
technology you guys make.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Topher.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]